[Music]
[Applause]
i would like to welcome you to this ftth
council awards session
and as you know we will be handing over
three awards
the operator award
the individual award
and the charles cow award
and i'll come to that in a minute as
well
first the operator award
is given to an operator company
that has made a clear decision in favor
of ftth in europe
the winner was not only selected on the
size of the network and investment made
but also on factors such as the
economical the political and competitive
environment for driving ftth rollout
we have chosen for city fiber uk
challenger and leader in the open access
service provider space
definitely in uk and perhaps even in
europe
from a startup to become number one
in five years
since founding in 2011 city fibre has
completed six acquisitions
and raised over 2.7 billion pounds in
capital
including the uk's largest capital race
for full fiber deployment
with over 1 million homes now ready for
service its 4 billion pounds rollout
is on track to serve a third of the uk
market by 2025.
extension to rural areas is also planned
via its government's project gigabit
program
city fibers infrastructure is designed
to serve consumer and business isps
councils and mobile operators
its modern architecture served by
state-of-the-art fiber exchanges has
already driven some of the biggest names
in the market such as vodafone talk talk
and three to make it their network
operator of choice
i would like to ask
mr greg mesh ceo of city fiber uk
to join us on stage for the handover of
this operator award
[Applause]
hello
[Applause]
let me hand over please mr mesh thank
you thank you well deserved thank you
they
thought if i could just say a couple
words and
and first i don't know how
we could ever follow the ukraine
speakers there because
we've come out of a two-year pandemic
which was a tragedy for everybody and
we've seen that the incredible power of
communications networks to serve for
good during a pandemic and then to come
out of that pandemic and then have a war
in our footsteps in a war that
has shaken us to our
but but also to realize that
communications networks are also driving
a critical element
of that whole program and some of the
first things they do is connect the
communications networks to allow us to
communicate so my hat's off to everybody
it also
means that focusing on mental health is
more important than ever
i would like to thank the fiber to the
home council i think it's done an
incredible job i've been with city fiber
for 11 years i've been building
communications networks in europe for
over 25 years in five different
countries
all in challenger mode and the fiber to
the home council has been one
one positive influence throughout the
whole thing of
a uniform message and that uniform
message is really that it's not fiber to
the home
it's world-class digital infrastructures
will power the economies of the future
fiber is it just the median that must be
used so i think it should really be
renamed i'm lobbying to be fiber for
everything in the in the future so i
really want to thank that also i'd like
to thank just because
after 11 years of work city fiber staff
and employees there's quite a few at the
show we attend it we really support it
but they know after 11 years that
working with me is is quite exhausting
anyway so i thank them for all their
support
and last my my wife is in the audience
raise your hand if you can it's our
anniversary yesterday of 24 years of
marriage
24
years and
think about this city fiber is 11 years
old so that's almost half our married
life she's listened to me whine about
city fiber and she says i work
tirelessly like a dog so if it's dog
years that means 77 years of my life
i've been working at city fiber to try
and push this forward
so thank you for that and then finally
i have to thank bt and virgin because
they have
tirelessly said there's no need for
fiber to exist tirelessly said there's
no need for city fiber to exist in fact
at this show two years ago three years
ago they said city fiber would go
bankrupt within two years
and let me explain just really clearly
what we have done in the last two years
we've gone from
a hundred thousand homes passed to one
point seven million
we've gone from ten thousand connected
homes to over a hundred thousand and
we're currently doing ten thousand a
month
we've gone from six hundred employees to
two thousand
we've raised 1.5 billion in capital
so i'd like to thank them for spurring
us on because it's really the
challengers in this room and the
challenger mentality that's really
driving this ecosystem forward
it's the challengers that look like
tesla
to the old incumbents with their old
ways of operating so i really want to
thank them also thank you thank you
do you want to want to take the third
secret
thank you greg
the individual award honors a
professional for the special efforts
made to enable ftth in europe
the nominee
can be a manager who has made a clear
decision to support ftth rollout a
technician for implementing a new
technology solution for ftth
or a decision maker who has contributed
to creating a favorable environment for
ftth
now we have chosen for iac visniewski
in three years jacques created from
nothing one of the biggest wholesale
fiber network operators in poland nexera
he constructed a core team which was in
it was able to roll out an ftth network
throughout the country
to more than 300 000 homes past in four
years with around 20 people
he created a cloud-based bss oss
environment with open apis and enabled
fully integrated zero-touch business
processes with retailers
great success
and a great manager
i would like to ask jacques visniewski
to join us on stage for the handover of
this individual award
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
thank you very much thank you very much
this is really honored and
i do really appreciated this this award
individual award
um
by making my
my my job
i never thought that i do really
something
extraordinary
i'm just trying to open people's eyes on
the things that i dream of
and they are afraid to
to reach for them
you know and i've been looking for my
professional way many many years i made
a lot of mistakes
but i learned from them
i also dared to make the hard decisions
and challenge the status quo
be proud but never satisfied
i was lucky i met
people who believed in me
trusted me and gave me the opportunity
to to manage nexera company
thank you info capital
i also
was so happy to
together around me people
who do
care
they want to change the world they want
to do something significant they want to
make the extra step
thank you nextera team
together
we can open the digital world thanks to
ftth technology
to the
citizens and inhabitants of small cities
and villages
and this is awesome
this is something
really
great
and last but not least
i would like to thank my wife
um
yeah
because she was the the first
the first one who discovered many many
years ago before ft2h council
the sparkles in my eyes
and she said go for it
thank you eva
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
now the charles cow award
was created in honor of fiber pioneer
professor sir charles quinn cow
who was awarded a nobel prize in physics
in 2009 for groundbreaking achievements
concerning the transmission of light in
fibers for optical communication
this award is presented to an individual
who has made an outstanding lifelong
achievement
and contribution to promoting full fiber
connectivity
we have chosen for mr alex goldblum
being one of the most well-known leaders
in the european fiber optic
and telecom industries
after a successful career at royal dutch
shell
he joined eurofiber and became its chief
executive officer in january 2007.
this has turned out to be a start of a
long successful and still continuing
journey
in which alex has led the growth of the
organization from startup through
scale-up to an established european
market leader
alex combines deep knowledge and
expertise of the market and operations
with an excellent m a strategy to back
up organic growth
he fine-tuned eurofiber's company
philosophy
of open access networks as a driver for
innovation and prosperity
a model that has not only proved to be
successful economically
but that is nowadays also accepted as
the most sustainable way
in which digital connectivity can be
realized
to date
15 years after alex started eurofiber
the company multiplied its network
which now counts 56 300 kilometers and
grows with over 40 kilometers a week
i would like to ask mr alex goldblum to
join us on stage for the handover of
this charles cow award
[Applause]
so now i have to thank my wife
which i do with all my hearts but it
wasn't part of the plan
she's in the netherlands at the moment
um thank you um yeah 16 years um i must
say what i heard this morning pals into
insignificance when i think about what
i've done the last uh 16 years so my my
thoughts are with everyone in the
ukraine
if i think about what we have achieved
as a company as an industry let's talk
about the industry
we've gone from the pioneering phase and
we're now into a much more mature
phase of our development as an industry
which is really exciting and i think
this is testament to this conference in
itself as testament to how far we've
come
and how far we can still go
because a lot of the easy work's been
done and now we're going to need to work
a lot closer together as an industry to
really get to that next level that means
coordination across the value chain it
means working together on some
significant policy areas we're going to
talk about sustainability we're going to
talk about dni we're going to talk about
lots of really important pieces that as
an industry we really need to address to
get to the next level
and i think what's really exciting and
i'm quite proud of this actually is the
fiber to the home council i've seen
quite a few platforms in the last 15 16
years come and go
and the fiber to the home council has
really secured that position as the body
that can bring the injury together so i
think there's a lot more work to be done
but it's a great great start and let's
use these types of events to work learn
from each other and make sure that we as
a policy influencing body have as much
clout as everyone else in the market
thank you very much
so
let us now invite once more for a nice
picture greg mesh from city fiber uk
jacik visniewski
from nexera and alex goldblum for a very
nice ftth family picture so if you want
to stand up and
grab your trophy please
and here in front of a nice picture so
please
yes i go closer thank you very much
thank you
thank you very much again and we close
by that the award session thank you to
all the awarded people thank you very
much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you